you're saying the complexity of the
human mind is uh
at least from our perspective nearly
infinite because there are meta
phenomena what sometimes gets described
as sort of levels of emergence where at
increasing levels of complexity you have
novelty evolved that you that you can't
predict from from lower levels of
complexity like for example atoms to
molecules you know it's just one example
I I think uh neurons to Consciousness
Consciousness to culture right that
there are meta phenomena that separate
from the phenomenon from the phenomena
underneath of them and and therefore by
adding an entire aspect of novelty so I
I think we are
I mean I really think this is true that
we are all infinitely fascinating
because these levels of emergence of
novelty that are inscrutable because you
can't predict from one level to the next
or understand fully are what make us and
not just us but I think sentient
creatures right human beings right but
sentient creatures inestimably more
interesting than than creatures that
aren't as sentient and and I don't know
I think when when we think about machine
learning and artificial intelligence I
think it's that that we're trying to
create levels of emergence that now we
don't fully understand anymore which I
guess is both exciting and maybe scary
too
yeah so he started the physics of atoms
uh quantum mechanics going to chemistry
going to biology
from the biology you have the functional
phenomena especially as manifested in
the human brain and then multiple brains
connecting together through
Consciousness intelligence creates
civilizations it's pretty interesting
where do you think the magic is and
which layer of the cake every layer
because every time you emerge from one
thing to another I see it as an analog
like the concept of the dialectic right
where I think it was Hegel right who who
realized
um hey when you have like thing a and
thing B and they're complicated and they
come together you know you don't get a
hybrid of A and B right you know you you
end up getting something that's new
that's novel and and I think that
describes to some degree that like what
emergence is except there's
there's a whole new and it's Universe of
novelty right that that comes at each
layer of emergence that allows infinite
possibilities that weren't possible
before and I think that's why we're so
complicated that we're our functional
Neuroscience right which I think is
psychology right our ability to think
about ourselves about others to be
reflective is sitting on top of so many
layers of emergence like the idea of
standing on the shoulders of giants that
we're you know each of us our
Consciousness is standing on the
shoulder of a giant of many many many
levels of emergence of novelty so many
of which we don't understand I mean
about subatomic particles everything
that that quantum physics means you know
when when does time become important
right as opposed to things happening
outside of time and outside of space
when do we slot into one temporal
perspective and then the complexity just
I think grows and grows and grows yeah
the interesting word you use is novelty
if true this really blows my mind in
some uh either shallow or deep sense it
is true I'm trying to figure that out I
don't know if you know something about
cellular automata is this very simple
mathematical objects where you have
rules that govern each individual little
cell and they interact locally and that
you know you understand the very simple
operation of those individual cells but
add another layer of abstraction when
you just kind of zoom out with blurry
vision these uh meta objects starts
appearing that function you could build
a touring machine whether you can build
an arbitrary complexity of of compute of
uh of computation on top of this kind of
very simple object yes it's an
interesting question whether
that was always there
the atoms
somehow know about love right like uh
about Consciousness
about war and violence and evil and hate
and all that that's already Laden in the
possibility of that the capacity for
that it's already in the atoms it's
already in the physics it's already in
the
in all the different chemistry that
builds up and it's like even the origin
of life
still a mystery that's that's known
that's in the physics that's known to
the universe the basic uh background
physics in the universe because if
that's not the case
it's like where does that come from
where's that magic
and how many layers can the cake
possibly have how many are we gonna keep
building if it's all if there's if we're
constantly through this process of
abstraction of adding a layer to the
cake adding novel things
like where's the ceiling
as we expand out into the cosmos if we
successfully can do that we're going to
keep building like more miraculous
complex objects and then the brain is
just like a middle layer
thing we tend to think of ourselves as a
truly truly special manifestations of
what's possible in the universe but
maybe we're just like the basic like
tiny building block of something much
much bigger we're in the early days of
being a brick and a very large building
sure look I think that's entirely
possible I mean I think the only
emergent thing so to speak that that we
build is culture right the aggregation
of us so you have individual human Minds
which are entirely unique I mean even
the fact that time is different for you
and me right it may be by Pico seconds
right but we can engage because our our
perceptions of time are parallel enough
they're close enough right that we can
share a reality right but we're all
living in a different dimension of time
right I mean we know that right so we're
unique in that way and then the Unique
Individuals that we are just like the
cells right start to create not just one
thing not just a culture but culture on
top of our individuality right there are
our uniqueness our even dimensional
uniqueness of of time and experience and
and Consciousness so we create cultures
on top of us but what could be Beyond
culture right and and what is different
from us either on underlying levels like
you know like quantum physics or
chemistry or biology or entirely
different and unconceived I think is
it's an immense question and I think
it's one that should create humility in
us right that look look how much we
don't know and then how Reckless we are
with ourselves with our Resources with
with human life and and I think there
it's uh it's important to say I mean you
think about how entropy rules
the universe around us I mean how over
selected are we how many not just
hundreds or thousands of times but how
many millions of times does there have
to be a selection Branch point before we
get into a sort of Eddie pool of counter
entropy right where you can begin to
create
right which which I think is why I say
okay do the atoms know about love right
the the the fact that anything is being
created right means there's this over
selection for counter entropy where
there can be a building of Greater
complexity of ultimately of novelty and
we don't often think about that of of
how far removed we are maybe light years
so to speak uh from any other location
temporally physically in the universe
where this could happen and we don't
think about what does that
mean